hey guys i am so excited to get into all
of the new phone news but before i do i
wanted to let you guys know that i am
hosting a really fun event this weekend
it's cadillac's charge forward live
stream event this is going to be
celebrating the all-new 2023
all-electric cadillac lyric this is the
cadillac of evs i got a sneak peek at
how more than a century of cadillac
innovation led to the inspiration of
this revolutionary new vehicle it's such
a tech forward all-electric vehicle and
i cannot wait for you guys all to check
it out the event has an amazing musical
performance from tinashe we've got some
amazing thought leaders in tech and
culinary and lewis of unbox therapy will
also be there live stream begins on
september 18th at 2 p.m eastern 11 a.m
pacific and it will be featured right
here on youtube.com following the event
you can go to cadillac.com to reserve
your all-electric 2023 cadillac lyric
debut edition starting at 4pm eastern
and 1pm pacific i look forward to seeing
you guys all there or actually you'll
see me there because i will be hosting
it anyway let's get into the new iphone
13 news
[Music]
so we now have four new iphone 13s we
have the iphone 13 the iphone 13 mini
the iphone 13 pro and the iphone 13 pro
max and what's kind of exciting these
are all being released at the same time
if you guys recall last year there was a
delay on the iphone mini and i think
that the iphone pros came out first i
feel like this is something that i
should know very well because i lived
and breathed it for the entire tech
season but either way all of them are
going to be out at the same time and i
think this is really exciting for people
who are looking to decide which one to
get before you had to wait if you wanted
the mini something else to note i've
been seeing all of your comments and
your tweets and everyone's like but it's
like the same phone i just got an iphone
12. well if you just got an iphone 12
that's really great because you don't
need to upgrade like there's really
there is no one's like forcing you no
one is coming into your home and taking
you to the apple store making you buy a
new phone you don't have to do anything
that you don't want to do
simple as that but a lot of these
upgrades are pretty significant if
people are looking to upgrade from an
older iphone like if you have an iphone
7 and you go to the iphone 13 or you
even go to the iphone 12 that is a huge
jump a lot of people
do not upgrade their phones every single
year but some of the upgrades for the
iphone 13 is there is a new camera
system and the previous version the
iphone 12 had a vertical layout so these
are now diagonal they do also have the
new sensor shift technology which is
where the actual sensor itself shifts to
alleviate any type of movement in the
actual phone so this is going to be able
to give you that stable video footage
that we know and we love of course this
will make for better low light photos
and sharper images there's also five new
colors there's a
there's a pink i was hoping for like a
super hot pink but i really wanted a
pink phone and guess what here it is
it's actually called pink it's not
called rose gold it's not called gold
the gold that kind of looks like the
pink and we just say that that's pink no
this is actually called pink i guess
we'll talk about the other colors
there's a blue there's a midnight a
starlight in a product red i've also
seen a bunch of people on twitter saying
they really like this new product red
color i'm gonna be really interested to
see what it looks like in person because
i feel like every single red that apple
does it's almost completely different
than the previous version i also like
that they're calling the new silver or
like the white phone starlight when they
first announced starlight like what is
that i don't even know what is starlight
they also did manage to make the notch
smaller about 20 percent and everyone is
like what would they stick up and i
still have the notch like when i read
tweets and people saying negative things
like that's how i hear it like that's
when i read it like
that's what i hear it does also have a
bigger battery and there is a new super
retina xdr display it has a brighter
screen up to 1200 knit peak brightness
which they're gonna be also making this
more power efficient and that's great
because you are getting longer battery
life with a brighter screen and of
course a higher performance with the a15
bionic chip which is 50 faster than the
leading competitors i'm not really sure
even like what that means because i
would be curious to see how much faster
it is than the a14 and i didn't see
those specs anywhere it also has an
improved normal engine for better
machine learning and this is where it's
kind of interesting because this whole
machine learning thing is going to be
really kind of aiding in this new
cinematic mode they talked about being
able to now rack focus and what's great
is you're going to be able to not only
do this on the iphone 13 but also on the
iphone 13 pro and this is kind of a
feature that i feel like normally would
only be out on the pro versions but it's
so exciting because you can do this on
the iphone 13 as well i'm so excited to
try this out it looked really
interesting in the actual event they
filmed like this whole little tiny like
cinematic movie all on the iphone i
think most people they would be like
that wasn't shot on an iphone there's no
way it's too incredible like look at the
focus it was actually really impressive
to kind of see the way that
the focus was able to shift it did still
kind of look like a phone was focusing
the thing that i really like is you will
have the ability to go back and refocus
something so it's basically like being
able to refocus a video
once it's already filmed it's pretty
cool like i can't do that with this
camera they've also got some magsafe
cases in some new matching colors
they've got the new leather wallet with
find my built in and i'm very excited
about that as i mentioned my recap the
sizing on these start at 128 instead of
64 and you can configure these up to 512
gigs and honestly it's really great that
they did decide to up this to 128
because i do feel like 64 gigs
especially shooting this higher quality
content like you're going to be filling
up your storage very very quickly even
if you are storing things on the cloud
the question that i'm always getting
from everyone is which iphone do i get
you probably would be perfectly fine
with an iphone 13 but i do miss having
the zoom lens it really does make a huge
difference when you're doing video and
you're taking photos so really if you
are a content creator
i really do think that you should get
the pro speaking of the pro the iphone
13 pro and iphone 13 pro max the most
exciting thing i think for me is getting
an upgraded telephoto lens it's now a 77
millimeter equivalent and this is going
to give you a 3x telephoto zoom kind of
cool because this is going to be on both
of the iphone pros in the iphone 12 last
year one of the only reasons that i
actually went and got the max version
was because i wanted that two and a half
x zoom because it wasn't on the iphone
13 pro it gets a little confusing like
things just sort of all get i don't even
know like this is something that i live
and breathe and i still get confused so
if you as a normal everyday person that
does not live and breathe this gets
confused
it's okay
we're all in this together so what you
need to know is the camera specs are
exactly the same on both phones and that
is thank you apple for just making this
so much easier for us the max version is
honestly a really big phone like if you
don't want a big display like you can
definitely get away with just using the
smaller version which may be something
that i do this year but then i feel like
probably gonna be like man i really wish
i had the max but do i do the same thing
that i did this year and i got the max
and the mini and those were kind of like
my two devices to be determined anyway
the new iphone 13 pros now have pro
motion display and this is something
that we're very familiar with on the
ipad pros but we can now have this
variable refresh rate so it can go all
the way up to 120 hertz and what this
means is the phone is actually going to
be auto adjusting the display so if
you're just looking at a photo it's able
to optimize but if i'm watching some 120
frames per second content that i just
filmed on my new iphone 13 pro it'll
then be able to automatically update the
screen refresh rate to be able to
display that more accurately like if
you've never really experienced
hertz display like it's actually really
pretty impressive and there is a huge
difference when you're looking at them
side by side so i think it's going to be
kind of cool for people who have never
been able to experience this before and
experiencing 120 hertz for the first
time you're going to be like
whoa they've also upgraded the storage
option up to one terabyte this is
something that i was hoping that they
did actually last year but honestly it's
it's fine i'm glad that now it's here
because i have officially filled up my
512 gig iphone 12 so this is perfect
timing so the design of the new iphone
13 pros looks very similar to the
previous version they do have the new
color of that sierra blue they've also
got the gold the silver and the
graphites which are very similar colors
to the previous versions again the notch
is also a little bit smaller and like i
said before they do have the all-new
camera system so this is going to be
aiding in those things like the
cinematic mode that they talked about
and then the new macro photos are going
to be really cool this is something that
we have seen on other phones like the
oneplus and samsung's but now it's it's
finally here to the iphone so i can hear
you guys saying well but everybody
already had it
well now we have it too all of the
cameras do have night mode including the
telephoto there's another really cool
feature that tyler is actually a huge
fan of their photographic styles so you
can customize these in-camera looks so
you don't have to actually edit your
photos so it's kind of like you are
editing the photo before you take it and
then you take the picture and it already
has your look applied to it and for me
my look is upping the saturation and
making it very contrasty it's like if
you look at my instagram or any photos
that i always post it's pretty
aggressive sometimes but
that's what i like something else
for us content creators and video people
i know that's what i focus a lot on but
that's basically that's my entire life
so that is something that is very near
and dear to my heart we're gonna be able
to shoot pro res video up to 4k 30
frames a second and hold on before we
get into that though i must say this is
also a little bit upsetting for people
who do decide to only get 128 gig model
you can only shoot prores 1080p and i
think the reason for this is because the
video files are going to be so huge that
they don't want you to completely just
take over your entire phone with
progress video i do feel like this might
be a little bit upsetting because i feel
like they kind of should have let you
have the option to do that maybe just
make it a shorter video i'm not sure so
if that is something that is important
to you just know that you're gonna need
to get the larger storage options so
that you will be able to shoot in 4k
prores in the future and the fact that
we can now shoot pro res dolby vision
hdr content on like a phone plus with
cinematic mode like i think that people
might be missing how huge this actually
is i'm i'm just thinking about it and
i'm
very very excited so the overall design
of the new iphones is very similar to
the previous version and i thought
for sure because the new ipad mini
had touch id integrated into it that
they were going to do that in the pros i
really really wish that they did
although having the apple watch be able
to unlock your iphone has made a really
huge difference but i still just wish
that they would have had the touch id in
the button you did it in the ipads you
could do it on here too please please
i also kind of thought that they might
officially switch to usbc because they
did also do it in the ipad mini it's
like i wanted them to do it but i also
kind of didn't want them to do it
because i already have so many lightning
cables and like everything just kind of
works together either way it's iphone
season it's tech season i'm excited
about the updates and again if you did
just get an iphone 12 you really don't
need to upgrade if you have an older
device then this is gonna be a huge
upgrade for you i would love to hear
what you guys have to say in the
comments below and i will see you guys
in my next video thank you guys so much
for watching be sure to subscribe so
you'll see the videos that i post when i
actually get these devices in studio and
i got a chance to chat with tim cook it
was like the best thing ever so be sure
to also go check that video out i'll put
a link in the description and with that
my friends i will see you in the next
video
bye oh my gosh pink iphone
can't wait
[Music]
you